who came up with this business model is
there somebody that you guys say well
the founder of this business model was
John Doe who used to be XYZ and he
taught us to do this because it worked
back into whatever hundreds is there
somebody that invented this system was
was it purely accidental
well you know Empire the idea of forming
Empires is as old as
you know modern sort of modern history
it's his oldest history basically
um but the real turn happens in Iran in
the early 1950s so when most of that
that gets uh elected president and again
very much like honey roll those he ran
on a platform that said the oil
companies we need the outcomes here but
they've got a pay a fair share of the
profits they make in Iran to the Iranian
people
and uh the British and the Americans
were the oil companies in play here
especially the British company the
company that became BP uh and the
British had no did not have a
relationship with Iran so they called on
the Americans and it was Eisenhower at
first it was Truman Truman refused to
get involved and then Eisenhower became
president he got involved and he tried
to convince uh most of that to uh to
change his ways and but it wasn't
Happening Now Eisenhower you know
ex-military General was very afraid of
nuclear war with the Soviet Union in
Iran borders the Soviet Union so he
didn't want to send troops in because he
was afraid that the Soviets would
respond by setting their own troops and
it could escalate to a nuclear war and
so he got together his secretary of
state and his head of CIA who were the
Dulles Brothers the infamous Alan and
John Foster dolas and they came up with
this plan and the plan was that they
identified a CIA agent a card-carrying
CIA agent named Kermit Roosevelt who
happened to be Teddy Roosevelt's
grandson
and Kermit Roosevelt was sent off to
Iran with literally with suitcases
filled with dollars
and a few friends a few you know
assistants and they launched this huge
campaign to discredit most of that and
you know they they bribed the police
they bribed the hoodlums in the streets
to go demonstrate in the streets they
bribed the Press they use this money to
convince the country
that or at least
to convince our country to convince the
world in a way that that this prime
minister was very unpopular and that he
was a Soviet puppet that he was a
communist and of course this is in the
in a time in the early 50s when when
there was this huge clash between
communism and capitalism you know that
the Cold War had really begun uh and so
there was this and in the United States
huge amounts of press that that that
that was paid for to to to to say that
this guy had to be taken out and So
eventually he was overthrown and it
seemed like a legitimate coup against a
guy who was evil to his country this is
this is you know the impression that was
conveyed to the world
and the shop around was brought in as a
CIA puppet basically and placed on the
throne the Peacock Throne and so the but
this was so successful and it was so
inexpensive you know a few suitcases
filled with dollars there's nothing
compared to sending in troops
and it was so safe in terms of if if if
uh if it didn't work then the probably
wouldn't have been War who knows what
would have happened to Kermit Roosevelt
but but there wouldn't have been a war
we wouldn't have we wouldn't there's
enough threat of nuclear war that it it
it marked a turning point where if
successive uh administrations in the
United States could say now listen we
don't have to go to war to exploit other
countries we can do it economically
there was one problem
and that was that Kermit Roosevelt was a
card-carrying CIA agent if he had been
caught it would have been very
embarrassing for the CIA for the US
government so very shortly after that
the decision was made to use private
Consultants like me
[Music]
wouldn't implicate the US government
got it so this is why when you went to
your NSA interview they said you may we
may not hire you but you may work with
one of the companies that we are in
partnership with exactly and that became
a very common practice now let me ask
you how many times did the NSA throw
companies like that under the bus saying
we had nothing to do with it we had no
business with them was it pretty common
practice through all the companies under
the bus once somebody screwed up well we
always knew that they they would do that
uh if we could if we screwed up but I
don't know how many that actually
happened to him because I think in
general uh you know we were pretty
successful people in my position were
pretty successful because these heads of
states that these countries had damn few
options really I mean they they knew the
options
[Music]